it's a crisis that's overwhelmed
immigration authorities on both sides of
the U.S Mexico border
thousands of migrants and refugees have
crossed into the United States in recent
days with many more arriving by the day
we are fleeing our country we are freely
in gangs who have killed their family
and hurt us a lot we need their U.S
support to enter this country because we
cannot return to our country
on Saturday the U.S Homeland Security
secretary Alejandro mayorcas was joined
by Honduran president xiomara Castro for
a visit to McAllen Texas
I believe that in our history we have
never seen an exodus of entire families
from our country seeking opportunities
due to the levels of violence
Hondurans along with people from
Venezuela and Haiti form the largest
group of migrants and refugees trying to
cross the border and U.S officials are
seeking new strategies to address the
worsening crisis
I am grateful to the Honduran government
for working with us to effectively and
safely return individuals to Honduras
Who are ineligible for relief in the
United States
across the border in Mexico migrant
numbers continue to Surge speaking at
the United Nations on Friday Mexico's
foreign minister Alicia Barcena said
Mexican immigration authorities are
ill-equipped to handle the number of
migrants and refugees arriving daily
this goes beyond the capacity that we
can bear even though Mexico is trying to
do a good job and even in the United
States the border patrol is overwhelmed
they have the capacity to process 1000 a
day but if 11 000 arrive it's very
difficult
though the Biden Administration has
called on Mexico and other Latin
American countries to do more to control
migratory flows the continued surge of
migrants and refugees at the U.S Mexico
border underscores the pressing need for
immediate action to address the
underlying factors driving migration
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera